en una tirada de dados.
En una novia que habían plantado en el altar.
Pero resulta que, este "nuevo" diagnóstico humano
no era ni nuevo, ni tampoco era exclusivamente humano.
Los veterinarios había diagnosticado, tratado e incluso prevenido
síntomas inducidos emocionalmente en animales,
desde monos a flamencos, desde ciervos a conejos,
desde la década de 1970.
¿Cuántas vidas humanas podrían haberse salvado
si este conocimiento veterinario hubiera estado en las manos
de paramédicos y cardiólogos?
Autolesión.
Algunos pacientes humanos se hieren a sí mismos.
Algunos se arrancan el cabello,
otros realmente se cortan a sí mismos.
Algunos pacientes animales también se dañan a sí mismos.
Hay pájaros que se arrancan plumas.
Hay corceles que repetidamente se muerden sus flancos hasta sangrar.
Pero los veterinarios tienen métodos muy específicos y muy eficaces
para tratar e incluso prevenir la autolesión
en sus animales que se autolesionan.
¿No se debería ponerse este conocimiento veterinario
en manos de psicoterapeutas y padres y pacientes
que luchan contra la autolesión?
Depresión postparto y psicosis postparto.
A veces, poco después de dar a luz,
algunas mujeres se deprimen,
y a veces se deprimen mucho e incluso se vuelven psicóticas.
Pueden descuidar su recién nacido,
y en algunos casos extremos,
incluso dañar al niño.
Los veterinarios equinos también saben que de vez en cuando,
una yegua, poco después de dar a luz,
descuidará el potro, negándose a lactar,
y en algunos casos, patean al potro, incluso hasta la muerte.
Pero los veterinarios han ideado
una intervención para tratar este síndrome de rechazo al potro
que implica el aumento de la oxitocina en la yegua,
la oxitocina es la hormona de la unión,
y esto lleva a un renovado interés,
por parte de la yegua, en su potro.
¿No debería esta información
estar en manos de obstetras y ginecólogos
y los médicos de familia y pacientes
que están luchando con la depresión postparto y la psicosis?
A pesar de esta promesa,
por desgracia, el abismo entre nuestros campos sigue siendo grande.
Para explicarlo, me temo que voy a tener que sacar unos trapos al sol.
Algunos médicos pueden ser unos verdaderos esnobs
con los profesionales que no son médicos.
Estoy hablando de los dentistas y lo optometristas y los psicólogos,
pero quizás especialmente los médicos de los animales.
Por supuesto, la mayoría de los médicos no saben que es más difícil
entrar en la escuela de veterinaria en estos días que a la de medicina,
y que cuando vamos a la escuela de medicina,
nos enteramos de todo lo que hay que saber
sobre una especie, el Homo sapiens,
pero los veterinarios deben aprender acerca de la salud y la enfermedad
en mamíferos, anfibios, reptiles, peces y aves.
Así que no culpo a los veterinarios por sentirse molestos
por la condescendencia y la ignorancia de mi profesión.
Pero esto es de los veterinarios:
¿Cómo llamas a un veterinario
que solo puede atender a una especie?
Un médico.
(Risas)
Cerrar la brecha se ha convertido en una pasión para mí,
y estoy haciendo esto a través de programas
como Darwin en Rondas de la UCLA,
donde estamos trayendo expertos en animales y biólogos evolutivos
y los juntamos en nuestros equipos médicos
con nuestros pasantes y nuestros residentes.
Y a través de las conferencias Zoobiquity,
donde juntamos las escuelas de medicina, con las escuelas de veterinaria
para discusiones colaborativas
sobre las enfermedades y los trastornos que comparten
los pacientes humanos y los animales.
En las conferencias Zoobiquity,
los participantes aprenden cómo el tratar el cáncer de mama en un tigre
puede ayudar a mejorar el tratamiento contra el cáncer de mama
en una maestra de preescolar;
cómo el entender los ovarios poliquísticos en una vaca Holstein
nos puede ayudar a tratar mejor
a una instructora de baile con períodos dolorosos;
y cómo el comprender mejor el tratamiento de la ansiedad por separación
en un perro pastor hipertenso
puede ayudar a un niño ansioso que lucha con sus primeros días de clase.
En los EUA y ahora internacionalmente, en las conferencias Zoobiquity
los médicos y los veterinarios dejan sus actitudes y sus preconcepciones
en la puerta y entran juntos como colegas,
como compañeros, como médicos.
Después de todo, nosotros los humanos también somos animales,
y es hora de que nosotros los médicos aceptemos
la naturaleza animal de nosotros y de nuestros pacientes
y nos unamos a los veterinarios
en un enfoque de la salud expandido de las especies.
Porque resulta que,
algunos de las mejores y más humanistas medicinas
se practica por los médicos cuyos pacientes no son humanos.
Y una de las mejores maneras en que podemos tratar
al paciente humano es prestando mucha atención
a cómo todos los otros pacientes en el planeta
viven, crecen, enferman y sanan.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)